[Applaus]
keine Ahnung wie es Ihnen geht aber
eigentlich macht ampelbching keinen
richtigen Spaß mehr weil es so
mainstream ist aber sie zwingen
einförmlich ich sage nur klimageld das
ist in dieser
Legislaturperiode nun wohl doch gar
nicht mehr kommt ist ein schwerer Fehler
der CO2 Preis ist gerade hochgegangen
wissen sie von 30 auf 45 € pro Tonne
deswegen kostet z.B der Liter Benzin
seit Januar im Schnitt über 4 Cent mehr
und falls Sie sich jetzt fragen
klimageld was war das noch mal
das ist ein Vorhaben des
Koalitionsvertrages dass wir in der Lage
sein wollen Einnahmen aus der CO2
Bepreisung an die Menschen
zurückzugeben ja genau hinhören er sagt
wir wollen in der Lage sein den Menschen
was zurückzugeben nicht wir wollen den
Menschen was zurückgeben so jetzt sind
sie aber weder Willens noch in der Lage
weil es immer noch nicht gelungen ist
unser aller Steuernummern mit den ibahn
zu verbinden und weil das Geld leider
irgendwie alle ist ja ist alle verplant
Weg ist so schade blöd also verstehen
Sie es bitte nicht falsch es kommt was
rein durch den CO2 Preis aber sie haben
schon für andere Sachen verplant z.B für
Wärmepumpen häusersanierung und Grüne
stahlfabriken das heißt Hausbesitzer und
Stahlproduzenten kriegen was aber wer
einfach nur tankt oder heizt oder lebt
guckt in die Röhre ne denken die
wirklich das kommt gut an bei den
Bürgern ich lass mal diese Frage im Raum
verhallen gute
Idee sehr gute Idee das würde ich auch
ja erst hießes klimageld kommt 2024 dann
25 neulich war in der Ampel sogar
plötzlich von
2027 die redeb 2027 auf alle Fälle auf
alle Fälle 2027 großes Ampel ehrenwort
also also spätestens 28 es sei denn es
fehlen noch ibans dann
29 so wenn der Staat diese Einnahmen
behält und nicht an uns zurückgibt dann
nennt man das Steuern und zwar
ungerechte denn sozial Schwache
Haushalte geben anteilig viel mehr für
tanken und heizen aus man muss halt
neuerdings Prioritäten setzen auch junge
Familien müssen sich wahrscheinlich bald
entscheiden noch ein Kind oder doch eine
Wärmepumpe ne vergleichen wir diese
beiden Produkte mal ganz nüchtern Babys
ja sie sind süß bis auf die hässlichen
aber sie haben eine katastrophale CO2
Bilanz sie können absolut nichts und sie
kacken einem die Hütte voll die
Wärmepumpe dagegen macht die Hütte warm
ist super fürs Klima und sie zieht nicht
mit 18 aus und will danach nur noch Geld
Fazit 3:0 für die Wärmepumpe ein
nobrainer es ist ein nobrainer AH Mensch
merke gerade jetzt haben wir doch schon
wieder mitgebächt das nächste
ampelbäching Kinder das geht doch auch
konstruktiver meint till
Reiners pimp my Ampel mit
motivationscoach
Reiners so ampelmusen genug geheult ihr
seid die Regierung ihr regiert jetzt
muss der Bürger das nur noch merken ja
ihr habt tierisch under performt aber
selbst euch kann ich in wenigen
Schritten nach vorne let's
go Punkt ein fucking Zuversicht Motto
wir haben 100% Bock auf die Zukunft egal
wie groß die Probleme sind mit dem
mindset können ihr wieder begeistern ich
nehme mir das zu Herzen und zugleich
weiß ich wir in Deutschland kommen
dadurch meine Fresse dann sag es deinem
Gesicht und guck nicht wie ein
Beerdigungsunternehmer trotzdem selbst
mit dem kann man noch Wahlen gewinnen
bisschen Typveränderung vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr Haare
Wagen ja und ans Gesicht müssen man
natürlich auch noch
ran ja
zack schon ist das
kanzlermaterial nächster Punkt sich auch
mal geil finden z.B hat die Ampel für
Ihren Haushalt gerade über 6 Milliarden
Euro gefunden ich weiß jetzt nicht warum
sie die verloren haben aber das ist ja
gar nicht der Punkt die Ampel hat zwei
Drittel ihrer Vorhaben aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag umgesetzt oder
angefangen die umzusetzen ruf den
Bürgern also zu wir sind die Ampel und
wir halten zusammen parteifze Wolfgang
kubiki glaubt nicht dass die Ampel 2025
erleben wird er sagt das Ende
voraus ja aber auch das kriegen wir hin
gar kein Problem kubiki ist ja Fan von
Kreuzfahrten die nicht bezahlen muss
spendiert dem eine Kreuzfahrt und dann
legt das Schiff einfach nie an Problem
gelöst weiter ganz wichtig mit den
Bürgern endlich wie mit Erwachsenen
reden wir können die Wahrheit vertragen
doppelums das Babysprache die Leute
wollen elich klare Aussagen und das kann
der Scholz ja auf Pommes Maru oder
Ketchup Mario
sieh du Sparpolitik und Kürzung ja aber
mit
Mayo es geht nicht mehr ohne Zumutung
die müssen nur gerecht verteilt werden
schade dass die Ampel jetzt steuerlich
vor allem besser Verdiener entlastet das
kann auch keiner nachvollziehen
geschweige denn feiern also sei denn man
ist Bundestagsabgeordneter bei der FDP
und spürt ansonsten gar nichts
[Musik]
mehr ja
super Energie nur die burtschaft ist
furchtbar pimp me Ampel und wo wir schon
dabei sind pimp auch mein Burger ja ja
rede ich jetzt mit euch ja ihr sitzt ja
rum einmal die Woche 30 Minuten und
lacht ab über die da oben und glaubt
damit die Welt zu verbessern dabei sind
wir doch alle unausstehlich wir wollen
mehr Tierwohl aber 5 kg Nackensteak für
1,99 die Ampel soll gefällig sparen aber
natürlich nicht bei mir Deutschland ist
wie so eine Baustelle wo nur noch drei
arbeiten und die anderen stehen meckern
daneben und sagen würde ich anders
machen ganz ehrlich ich würde mich nicht
regieren wollen auch wir müssen besser
werden spontan Übung ich zähle jetzt bis
drei und dann rufen ihr alle mal rein
was ihr am geilsten findet an der Ampel
1 2
3 ich gehe nach Hause ich auch Reiners
meine Damen und Herren vielen Dank so
Kinder ich hoffe die Kamera läuft denn
ich halte nicht ab
abonniert den Kanal hier Danke euer
Gerner tasknecht so ich gehe wieder nach
Hause schönen Feierabend Jürgen ciao